I have always been fascinated by the
search for life aliens from outer space
come to mind
but I'm inspired by animals in another
final frontier the oceans mid waters are
one of the least explored places on
earth full of creatures that defy
imagination
I'm dr. Koo Connie cotija I'm a bio
engineer at the Monterey Bay Aquarium
Research Institute and a National
Geographic Explorer
my work focuses on developing
technologies to access the deep dark
ocean bringing to light organisms we
know almost nothing about
and I'm Bari we are a world leader in
ocean research connecting discovery with
innovation science with engineering and
ultimately an alien world with our own
we're about to embark on a week-long
expedition to the Monterey submarine
Canyon which reaches depths of nearly
4,000 meters
located off the coast of Central
California Monterey Bay is home to one
of the most diverse ocean ecosystems on
the planet it's also known as the
Serengeti of the sea
accessing this difficult to study
ecosystem requires state-of-the-art
tools and a highly specialized crew of
engineers and technicians
and barri operates two research vessels
the Western flyer for longer multi-day
expeditions and the Rachel Carson used
mainly for one day trips out to sea each
vessel has a dedicated remotely operated
vehicle or ROV on board and is outfitted
with specialized systems that enable
expeditions throughout the world's ocean
we'll be deploying to our Ovie's on this
trip collecting footage and samples of a
wide variety of animals some of which
are brand new to science
da crickets is he five and a half ton
robot that can dive to depths of 4000
meters and has conducted more than 1,200
research dives
we use high resolution cameras to find
approach and document all kinds of sea
life
what we see through these ro bees often
reminds me of flying through space life
in the mid waters this region between
the sea surface and the ocean bottom is
home to captivating creatures like
speedy translucent worms jellyfish
longer than a blue whale and one of my
favorites the giant larvae ssin which
makes its house out of mucus these are
organisms with astounding adaptations to
life in an extreme environment
this animal is a worm called tamaak
Duras
these animals are incredibly fast and
maneuverable swimmers capable of
movements of fish could never achieve
[Music]
this is gala two--this also known as the
cockatoo squid it has a transparent body
and photo force or light organs under
its eyes we often encounter the species
pain horizontally in the water column
with its arms above its head
[Music]
here we are delicately capturing a squid
through a section sampler in all da
crickets can collect nearly 30 animals
in one dive which we bring up to our
laboratory for further study
in the lab we use a variety of
techniques to study all aspects of our
collected specimens their complexity
drawn from hundreds of millions of years
of evolution can inspire new ideas and
innovations from propulsion to medicine
filtration to optics there's a lot we
can learn from these animals
we're only just beginning to scratch the
surface
there's a universe of discovery waiting
for us down there
you